[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
LegalZoom which more than 2 million
Americans have used to help start their
businesses past guests even such as well
WordPress lead developer CEO of
automatic Matt Mullenweg now valued at
more than a billion dollars have used
LegalZoom to help with their business
needs specifically in his case to form
his company but LegalZoom isn't just for
launching your business their services
include everything from helping you to
manage changing tax laws reviewing
contracts creating NDA's non-disclosure
agreements important stuff handling
lease agreements and assisting with
really any other legal challenge hurdle
inconvenience that typically takes time
and effort away from running your
business the best part is that you won't
get charged by the hour
because LegalZoom isn't a law firm so
they won't be running the clock up and
spinning circles just to raise your bill
instead they just ask you to pay one low
upfront price for whatever it is that
you're looking to get a la carte style
so visit legalzoom.com and check out
their business section for all their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and the copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is folks but it's
titillating if you want special savings
enter promo code Tim T I am at checkout
capital T lower case I am again take a
peek legalzoom.com and enter promo code
to him
this episode is brought to you by helix
sleep last year I focused on
dramatically improving a few things
surprise surprise most notably the
quality of my sleep which seems to
affect just about everything this led me
to revisit you name it
my daily routine morning routine
exercise diet all the way to what I
slept on and I ended up getting all new
beds here in Austin Texas including
mattresses from helix sleep helix has
built a sleep quiz that takes two
minutes to complete and they use the
answers to match your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper
hot sleeper cold sleeper or you like
plush you like firm with helix there's
no more guessing or confusion just go to
helix sleep calm forward-slash Tim take
their two minutes sleep quiz and they'll
match you to a mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life that is
their promise for couples helix can even
split the mattress down the middle
providing individual support needs and
feel preferences for each side they have
a 10 year warranty and you can test
drive your mattress for 100 nights
risk-free right now helix is offering up
to 125 dollars off of all mattress
orders so check it out get up to 125 off
at helix sleep comm forward slash Tim
that's helix sleep dot-com forward slash
Tim for 125 dollars off your mattress
order tickle ik
helix sleep comm forward slash Tim
well hello boys and girls this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show where it is my
job every episode to interview and
deconstruct world-class performers to
tease out how they do what they do this
episode we have a real treat someone you
may not have heard of a believe this is
his first ever podcast Nick Norris in my
mind he is the ultimate quiet
professional probably the most
understated person I've ever had on this
podcast he is an 11 year Navy SEAL
officer he served with Jocko willing cat
SEAL team 3
you may recognize that name Jocko also
another person who made their podcast
debut here and on top of that he is a
world-class athlete which I didn't
really fully appreciate until after our
conversation startup CEO and board
member of the c-4 foundation which is a
new foundation that focuses on
supporting active-duty SEAL families and
you can find that at c4 foundation.org
we talk about a lot in this episode and
cover a lot of ground ranging from his
training tips physical training tips
this human has no physical weaknesses
it's really impressive to post-traumatic
stress versus post-traumatic growth
differentiation talking about how you
separate those two talking about say
traumatic brain injury and the links to
depression evidence-based treatments
including some very new treatments for
depression PTSD and chronic stress many
people don't realize that approximately
20 veterans and active duty military
personnel kill themselves every day that
means that suicide has killed far more
veterans than any enemies whatsoever and
it is a a quiet crisis and a quiet
epidemic that I wanted to address on
this podcast there are lots of tactics
lots of stories let me give you a bit
more bio on Nick he is a graduate of
both the United States Naval Academy and
basic underwater demolition SEAL buds
class 247 upon completion of SEAL
training in 2004 Nick assumed
progressively higher positions of
leadership within Naval Special Warfare
his deployed roles included combat
advisor to Iraqi and Afghan military
units cross-functional team leader and
Ground Force commander
during combat operation in both Iraq and
Afghanistan nick was most recently
assigned to Naval Special Warfare basic
training command SEAL qualification
training sqt
his officer in charge prior to
transitioning off of active duty
he's also co-founder and CEO of alma
vara a sunscreen company that has
invented a new mineral sunscreen
technology to protect both consumer
health and the environment you can find
more about that at Amara dot-com let's
talk about some of his physical
accomplishments which were sent to me
after this podcast but just very briefly
he raced as a member of the US team in
the 2007 adventure racing World
Championships in Scotland he's raised in
multiple races of this type that are
multi-day world-class expedition length
races he has also completed ultra
distance trail running events between
50k and 50-plus miles in length he
competed as related to indoor skydiving
in the 2018 Sakura Cup Invitational as
part of the u.s. dynamic four-way team
that was Japan's very first
international indoor skydiving
competition a very high level
international dynamic flying tournament
that showcased the most talented
Windtunnel flyers in the world and as it
relates to bouldering so rock climbing
he has personally contributed to the
development of the Southern California
bouldering areas and has climbed a V 11
with the goal of climbing V 12 this year
at age 37 to put that in perspective
that places him pretty squarely in the
top 0.1% of climbers worldwide and you
can find Nick on Instagram at Nick
underscore Norris 1981 on Instagram so
with all that said please enjoy this
wide-ranging conversation with Nick
Norris
Nik welcome to the show thanks for
having me so I thought we could start
with Tokyo and it is certainly one of my
favorite places having spent a good
amount of time there and I told you as
we were having brunch little earlier to
save the story because I I don't like to
hear things a second or third time when
I'm having these podcast conversations
but it seemed like there was quite a bit
to dig into so your first trip to Tokyo
what took you there so I went out there
with a four-person team to compete in a
dynamic four-way windtunnel competition
called the Sakura Cup okay so the these
Sakura Sakura is the cherry blossom but
what on earth
I heard wind tunnel then there are a
bunch of different phrases associated
with that that should make no sense to
me and sound vaguely obscene what was it
okay so dynamic four-way is a discipline
of wind tunnel flying that you know it
probably started I'll probably butcher
this people will correct me but that's
okay the Internet's good for that right
six seven years ago maybe longer where
you know guys you know predominantly in
Europe these guys whose team name was
the Skywalker's they started flying a
lot of tunnel time and you get bored
just kind of doing normal vertical
formation skydiving so ecstatic
formation building for time and I think
they started moving around the tunnel
with like two people and then adding
three and four and then this thing has
blossomed into a full-on discipline
where you compete in two different I
guess formats you do a series of speed
rounds so you have a I guess II a number
of different movements either in a
vertical plane or a horizontal plane
that are predetermined and you fly them
in your three of those in succession
three times for time you enter the
tunnel and then exit the tunnel and then
you get a time and you compete against
each other so you have to hold a
specific position for for increasing
periods of time so you're moving the
entire time so think like synchronized
swimming
but flying around in a high-speed column
of air you know like a glass cylinder
gosh wall mm-hmm so you do that and then
the other portion is an artistic round
so you do a a 90 second artistic round
goddess that's like a breakdance battle
yeah it's like British they actually
call it battling no you get a new battle
against another team what would people
want to search online to find videos
those are the are there any particular
videos or search terms you suggest
people start with they want to see what
this actually looks like oh man so if
you put d 4 w like wind tunnel into
google it'll pull up a whole bunch of
videos and there's some super elite
fliers that we saw out in japan that
were way better than our team and even
if you look the Sakura Cup Windtunnel
competition there'll be some videos of
the rounds that were flown it's like
like really really impressive athletes
in a very fringe outlandish sport so you
you have a whole range of skills and
attributes that you've developed and we
shall not name the person who will not
be mentioned who's sitting also in the
room with us he is a snake eater in the
shadows who prefers to remain as such
but he described you initially to me in
a number of very sort of laudatory ways
and then he said he doesn't have any
physical weaknesses yeah it's really
annoying and haha so I thought we could
shift to another area that you've
explored quite a bit which is I'm gonna
prompt and then we can jump into it
because I said save it save it save it
for the podcast let's talk about moon
boards what on earth is a moon board
okay so a moon board is a it's a thing
that was created by a very famous rock
climber whose name is Ben moon out of
the UK and Ben is like I mean he's like
og like strong rock climber super
inspirational you know did some of the
hardest sport climbs in the world and
some of the hardest boulder problems in
the world
Ben started a company called moon
climbing and he he has this really
famous place called the schoolroom in
the UK it's his training gym and he had
this thing aboard a templated board that
has holds on it that never change so he
has these problems that have just been
there forever like some of the hardest
problems I think he said he's ever done
or on this board how big is the board oh
man and I'll be off on that is Riley
yeah so it's probably three so maybe 12
feet long
I think it's set at a 40 degree angle so
it's overhanging so it's like three
consecutive sheets of plywood and maybe
a touch more and it's gridded so set
distance in between each bolt hole and
then created a specific set of climbing
holds with a compass rose on them so
that's one on them a compass rose so
like a North arrow so you would go he
basically told you where to set you know
this number hold in this orientation in
this grid square or in this bolt hole
and by doing that you set the board a
certain way and he was able to create
Boulder problems that people could
replicate all over the world by just
building this exact copy of his moon
board and it's caught on like wildfire
in the climbing community they're all
over the place in commercial climbing
gyms where's the strangest place that
you have used strange or atypical place
you've used a moon board so I on active
duty built three moon boards I built one
in zamboanga in the Philippines I built
one in Ramadi Iraq and then I built one
in Zabul province at a firebase called
Na Bihar how long does it take to build
a moon board well I I had once you've
had once you've had a rehearsal on on
one or two so I'm a terrible carpenter
so I'm really good at convincing people
to help me do other things that I can't
do so I had a talented group of Seabees
combat construction guys that I
convinced to shirk all their other
responsibilities and
climbing wall in the middle of combat
zones so let's talk about these these
two disciplines just to start with
because I I find that generally well I
find it interesting how someone like
yourself looks at different disciplines
and I'm fascinated with high-performing
cohorts of people in any discipline
right it really doesn't matter it could
be carpentry could be rock-climbing
could be painting and just really the
the discipline itself is less
interesting than the the commonalities
among the top performers so if we look
at for instance the synchronized
swimming in an air column what separates
it could be in any of the different
formats you described it doesn't have to
be it could be in the battle format
could be in any any of the two
performance we discussed what separates
the good from the truly exceptional okay
and what are the characteristics or the
the defining practices anything that
you've been able to pick up since you
are very accomplished in this area as
well as in climbing yeah what separates
the good from the great
yeah I mean so there's a number of
things but I think time together as a
team being able to read people's body
language flying in a wind tunnel I mean
you start to see how people Telegraph
certain movements and you learn that
through repetition and just time
together so I mean I think that that
time as a team that kind of I guess you
can call it that kind of stress
inoculation you do it so many times that
you can just see you kind of predict
where people are going to go just by how
they look
moments before they do something so I
think that's one of the biggest in kind
of attributes that you know the high
high end teams have and then you know I
think the other thing is just their
ability in that discipline their ability
to move constantly like no hesitation
moving almost with no fear that they're
gonna impact each other because you're
you're talking about flying in a very
confined space at very high speeds and
you just trust
you have total trust that the guy that's
in front of you or behind you is gonna
do his job really well what when you say
high-speed for people who have no
exposure to this because for instance
I've spent one or two sessions in a
single day at an eye fly facility and
yeah I want to say in the East Bay in
Northern California many many many many
years ago which was a phenomenal
experience but I was so concerned with
just not eating it face-first into
something that I wasn't paying much
attention sir yeah wasn't paying a whole
lot of attention to speed I don't think
my input would have mattered but so what
is what is high-speed so like a lot of
wind tunnels will fly anywhere between
150 and maybe a hundred and seventy mile
an hour wind so they're they're pushing
vertical wind speeds at like 150 170
miles an hour and when you're flying in
that wind you're not going 170 miles an
hour you're flying you know upside down
or right side up in a vertical
orientation and I mean when you see like
the guys that are really really good I
mean they're moving they're probably
going I mean maybe 20 miles an hour I
mean 30 miles an hour of a closing speed
so like really fast I mean you can get
going if you were in the sky like
jumping out of an aircraft I mean you
could be moving a hundred and 20 miles
an hour over ground if you were in one
of the orientations you're flying at a
tunnel got it so you'd be covering we
were talking a little bit earlier about
wingsuits Rana and so those people who
haven't seen a wingsuit a it's
terrifying be the humans tend to
resemble flying squirrels there's a high
mortality rate and then there's another
term for it which is proximity flying
why is it called proximity flying okay
so I will say this for the record I
don't base jump I never have and I don't
proximity fly but I have a bunch of
friends that do so it's flying very
close to like land masses so when you
base jump you know the guys you watch
guys wingsuit very close to the side of
a mountain
Ridgeline and what can there and and you
mentioned I suppose
just moments ago 120 miles an hour so
are they achieving those types of speeds
yeah even I mean probably faster so they
you know they're glide ratio over ground
is like three to one or higher so
they're they're traveling three feet for
every foot that they descend and so like
really fast speed over ground if we look
at rock climbing to throw the same
question out there and you and you could
use a specific example if you wanted in
terms of picking someone who you
recognize as an elite climber but if if
we try to separate the inborn attributes
that allow them to be superior climbers
right much like you would I can't learn
to have my ankles seemingly dislocate
like Michael Phelps so that's that's
unlikely to be something I can train for
but there are different training
approaches or ways of looking at say
bouldering problems or other things that
might allow people to progress faster
and develop faster than others what are
some of the differentiators that you've
observed in exceptional climbers versus
people who are just kind of like me and
half of the things I do like permanent
blue belts we never quite graduate you I
think it's an innate ability to just try
hard like try very very hard and you
know that sounds easy but it's much more
difficult in practice you know you look
at you know there's a guy named Adam
Andra you you know arguably is the most
talented or the strongest rock climber
in the world
um just amazing to watch the guy climb
and you can see the level of tenacity
like just the the way that he approaches
climbs where he just does not give up
it's just a relentless pursuit of
perfection and like an endless pursuit
of perfection and the guy is magnitude
stronger kind of than the average you
know even elite level climber and is
still just you mean trains tirelessly to
get
and yeah I think that it's that that
that grit that ability just to continue
to persevere which you know is a huge
standout attribute how is that something
that you can develop I mean is there a
sort of mental theater in which you how
you speak to yourself allows you to do
that or helps you to do that I'm just
wondering what if people wanted to try
to develop the ability to try harder
which which I think can be done I mean I
think that there's there's there certain
presets yeah right but then if you are
training in just about any sport or area
with say a coach who believes you can
exceed what you take to be your
limitations then you can begin to sort
of instill the conditioned default of
trying really hard right so that I think
there are probably things that you can
do how do you approach say a new problem
that you've set out for yourselves I
know that you have have explored some
virgin territory when it comes to
bouldering problems maybe first you can
explain to people who don't rock climber
are familiar with it like what is
bouldering and then when you're tackling
a new problem like what is your what is
your internal voice sound like when
you're when you're tackling something
that you know is probably gonna be
pushing your level a bit yeah so to
start bouldering in the realm of
climbing is like powerlifting as it
relates to weight lifting or weight
training so small very intense
technically difficult pieces of terrain
that you're climbing with no rope and
crash pads laid out underneath you so
you're not soloing doing something
that's death-defying you know most of
the time it's you know less than 15 feet
off the ground so it's a very high
intense pursuit in climbing as opposed
to sport climbing or traditional
climbing which is a little bit longer
more endurance based you know for me
it's I know that tenacity or the ability
to persevere or something that's I'm in
control of and you know I was never the
most
talented athlete growing up you know I
just I always I wrestled as a young guy
and I didn't have the innate talent that
a lot of my peers at but I knew that I
could work hard and I could do all these
things in the offseason and even during
competition to to help get me closer to
be on a level competitive playing field
as these other people so I approached
bouldering in a very similar sense you
know I'm shorter I have shorter arms I'm
probably a little heavier than the
average Boulder Borden what are your
dimensions some people wondering so I'm
five foot six I have a negative to a
pinned X that means my wingspan my arms
are 5 foot 4 so I'm shorter stubby arms
and I weigh in anywhere from my gamma
and 60 165 pounds um so I'm not heavy by
any means but in the realm of climbing
I'm a little bit heavier for my size
yeah so I I feel I like I have it it
gives not obvious to people just based
on the context you're all so I mean
that's a lean that's not a Donuts and Dr
Pepper 170 I've been trying to get my
legs to be smaller
should I weigh less okay so the see see
you have the this variable which is
training intensity and consistency which
is under your control and like some of
the sort of innate talent that other
people might have then then if you are
just from a from a psychological
perspective when you are getting ready
to attempt whether it's the first time
or the fifth time a very hard root how
do you prepare for that like in the in
the minutes leading up to it what does
that look like so in in the moment if
like before I'm gonna give something
like a red point attempt like try to
actually climb though the line try to
clear your head I mean it's a huge
mental game when you get to the point
where you've done all the moves you're
strong enough to do it there's there can
be a big mental block and I think a lot
of athletes experience that you know
kind of been that kind of higher
echelons of performance so I think
clearing your brain and
not letting that be the the limiting
factor hmm I think leading up to that
it's practicing grit and kind of that
try hard in all of the structured
training that I do leading up to that
moment
so fingerboarding is a way that you you
can train your fingers you know your
tendon so a connective tissue to be
stronger
you know in every fingerboard workout
you know trying to apply that level of
grit that trihard you know hang on
things that might hurt my skin or just
be very you know rigorous and tough on
me trying to put that same level of
intensity into every training session
trying to get like high quality training
not just volume of training and checking
the boxes yeah this is this is what I
was hoping we'd explore a bit because I
mean repetition like practice does not
make perfect
no okay practice makes you more right
and I think a lot of a quote that I'm
gonna butcher the name that I need a
classic scholar in the room but arca
locust I think is one of these old old
names that is difficult to know how
exactly at least for me I was pronounced
but the the phrase is we do not rise to
the level of our hopes or expectations
we fall to the level of our training and
so if you haven't stress inoculation as
you mentioned it's very difficult to
execute when you're actually trying to
push yourself to a performance rep right
and so let's talk about clearing your
mind so practically what does that look
like so a lot of people get wrapped up
right they've put in a ton of practice
and then it's time to go out and perform
and you've no doubt seen this and I mean
we're gonna segue to military shortly
but whether it's in sports in any high
performance situation you see people who
do really well in training and rehearsal
and then they freeze right and then you
see people who are the opposite who do
really well under pressure and they may
not in training be the standouts but
then when it comes to actual performance
for it for any number of reasons they
are kind of in pole position so how do
you clear your mind so for me the things
that are the times where I've
my best I've actually used visualization
I have actually adopted that
successfully and you know it may not
work for everybody but I literally tried
to visualize myself climbing through all
the movement that I know I've done I've
practiced in the past I've successfully
executed it and in watch myself climb
through the entire boulder problem even
to the point where you know I will find
myself moving my hands in the positions
that they should be hitting each
specific hold you know just grabbing the
air and I just recently and like I'm I'm
constantly trying to pursue a higher
level of bouldering and I'm not by any
means the strongest Boulder in the world
but just recently I had this kind of
breakthrough experience on a really hard
boulder problem for me and right before
I did it I had been visualizing
literally the entire day leading up to
it and then just sitting down and
breathing you know a couple big deep
breaths and just trying to like empty
all their thoughts out of my brain
mm-hmm and we're gonna we're gonna segue
into how the military entered the
picture in a moment but what other what
other physical feats are you proud of
stuff this could be military or could be
civilian even if it's actually looking
for this different different way because
you're so understated if someone else
were to brag on your behalf I might have
to pull in some reinforcements here if
necessary but what other physical feats
or whether it's in competition or
otherwise are you are you proud of stuff
well so the prelude to that is that I've
surrounded myself with people that are
better than me in every athletic pursuit
that I've you know fallen in love with
so some of it beyond climbing I mean
climbing I've surrounded myself with
very talented people and I'm very proud
of some of the progression I've seen in
that sport prior to that I got way into
like longer distance running you know I
and you know 50k 50-miler like a lot of
trail races so I did my first 50-miler
on the East Coast when I was at the
Naval Academy with a handful of friends
and you know didn't know what to expect
and you know that was a big
accomplishment for me you know more
mentally you know it wasn't that you
were going super fast or you're gonna
win the race it was just kind of
persevering and being it was the grit
that you had to show through that I've
competed in some multi sport races like
Adventure Racing back in the day I did a
lot of like one day 2 day 3 day races
raced in eco primal quest back in 2002
in Telluride Colorado what is that it's
a so Eco challenge was made famous by
Mark Burnett and I think it was
developed after the raid Galois so all
map encompass a team of three or four
people and normally one person of the
opposite sex and it was all man powered
movement over terrain paddling hiking
mountaineering mountain biking um just
put you out in the middle of nowhere and
like the most epic places in the world
and it was it was sleep deprivation is
factored in and I think that's what drew
me to it more than anything else I mean
I knew I wanted to to go to buds and be
a seal and like I figured this was
probably the best kind of train up for
like mental toughness that I could do so
I got way into it when I was at school
so how did you end up becoming
interested in becoming a Navy SEAL or
being directed towards that territory at
all I mean how did that all start you
know I somebody mentioned this this
community within the military the SEAL
Teams when I was in like seventh grade
and before that I knew nothing about you
know the SEAL community and I think I
I've always been really good at setting
goals for myself and just working really
hard to achieve these goals because I
can have a lot of innate talent and
uh I think I fixated on that as a really
kind of almost unattainable goal when I
was seven in seventh grade and you know
just latched on to it I mean I just
wanted to achieve that and I had a lot
of people that were naysayers along the
way that doubted my ability to go and do
that but I knew that I was in control of
my destiny you know I could put the
structure together to achieve all the
small goals that would lead up to you
know ultimately ultimately realizing
that that bigger goal how did you end up
having even the concept of structuring
it in these these incremental bites
taking this large goal and breaking it
down is that something that your parents
demonstrated is it something mentors or
coaches demonstrated where did it come
from a book I mean where did that come
from
yeah so my dad was was instrumental on
that um growing up so my dad was a
college football player firefighter in
the city of Chicago really like addicted
to fitness like really into like
calisthenics and weightlifting got me
into that when I was pretty young and he
I can visualize it right now he had all
these like motivational quotes written
in like calligraphy up on the wall in
the basement in Chicago and he'd always
you know quote Vince Lombardi and and
and really push me to just try hard and
and start working out because you know
he was he was all about discipline you
know setting these goals so I like I
probably embodied that because I was
just in that environment with my dad and
I looked up to him a lot yeah he's I
mean I would imagine with the weight
lifting I don't know and you mentioned
wrestling as well I mean at least for me
where a lot of the kind of methodical
tracking began was with training and
weight cutting and so on because you
wanted to have a training log of some
type right to track to track progress so
you have this you have this dream that
is kicked off in some way around seventh
grade when does it start to become a
reality you know I think I went to the
Naval Academy you know it was accepted
to the Naval Academy started down that
path
super-competitive from the Naval Academy
to get a billet as an officer into the
SEAL training pipeline so I think it
started well it is like a position yeah
like an opportunity like you get one
slot to go on and in attempt the
training so I think at school that's it
I started to build this like really cool
camaraderie like a fraternity with the
guys who were all competing for that
finite number of spots into the seal
pipeline and you know I think back I
think I got it I got hooked on on that
Brotherhood like the fraternity that you
had a bunch of guys that all aspired to
do the same thing all sacrificing to
achieve that one goal and yeah I would
probably point back to that moment or
that period in my life as kind of that
was when I really start seeing it
manifest as reality is there any aspect
of buds or any any part of the training
/ vetting process that you and you
expect it would be most difficult or
that you were concerned about I was
always concerned about the cold I'm a
pretty thin guy I don't have a lot of
insulation on my body and I remember
going through some screening events at
school and getting extremely cold and so
that was something I you know it's
bright in the back of my head is a big
fear like would I get too cold like
would my you know my my mind you know
quit on me in that scenario because it
starts to really test you you know I
think beyond that I was never that good
of a swimmer I had kind of an example
when I was a junior in high school I was
a Chicago Park District lifeguard on the
lakefront at lately you know the shore
of Lake Michigan and they the senior
guards used to make me wear a rescue
buoy out when we'd go and do swim
because they thought I was gonna drown
so I was a terrible swimmer never swam
until I had my dad actually was the one
that told me you need to go get a job
go be a lifeguard it pays really well
and you get to hang out at the beach I'm
like great well I don't know how to swim
so I need to figure that out and then
you've at the Naval Academy I mean I I
think my senior year I probably swam
like four times in preparation for buds
it's thankfully you put fins on after
like the first week of buds and you do
all your swimming with fins so I was a
fairly good thinner but I was a terrible
swimmer you mentioned a term earlier
that I think is is worth exploring a bit
that's stress inoculation could you talk
about maybe give some examples of that
and maybe some so also some
misconceptions I mean for instance one
that came up yesterday when we're having
dinner was cold exposure sure and I was
actually you know I've never really
thought about it but the
counterintuitive aspect of that example
of things is worth mentioning too so
what is stress inoculation and where do
people sometimes get it wrong yes I mean
in its simplest form stress inoculation
is just exposing yourself to you know
stressors through experience to get you
you more comfortable so you can
inoculate yourself to stress and pretty
much any environment that would impose
it and I think the example that we are
talking about the misconception that we
were discussing yesterday was cold
exposure or exposure to heat you know if
you you put yourself in cold water
thinking that you're gonna build up this
tolerance to the cold I think it's
actually it actually works against you
you you could be more susceptible to
hypothermic fire and then the same thing
with hyperthermia yeah you know you get
heatstroke once you're gonna you're a it
could be a victim of heatstroke
repeatedly yeah yeah that's actually
ended up happening to me with Heat
specifically I've never told our our
mystery friend sitting here this before
but the I was a subject I volunteered to
be an experimental subject in testing at
Stanford where they had
I wanted I wanted the data right I had
always been susceptible to heat and I
wanted some some hard numbers on how
susceptible I was or if I was like what
the actual problem was and so they put
in
it's about as pleasant as it sounds an
anal probe which is a like a to measure
core temperature so it's like 18 inches
long or something like that and then
they had new technology which is an
esophageal probe so you also had like an
18 inch probe going down your nose down
your throat to try to get close to your
heart and then they put you in full
military gear with weighted rucksack
helmet and put you in a sauna on a
incline treadmill and just March you to
heat exhaustion yeah it was it was about
as pleasant as it sounds but I ended up
being more sensitive over time which I
didn't expect right I thought well this
is gonna be like building up a base
suntan and just so happens it's not true
for everything right I there's there's
there's someone who's who may be a a
character in the story of stress
inoculation and your exposure to that I
suppose pun intended who's been on this
podcast before can you describe how you
know Jaco willing so Jaco and I served
at SEAL team 3 together so when I was a
new guy he was the sister troop
commander and he and his troop went to
Ramadi that summer and then we were
deployed about 20 kilometers to the east
of Ramadi so I worked up with with jakku
and then Jocko took over our training
detachment on the west coast for the
SEAL team so I when I was a platoon
commander I took my platoon through the
entire training cycle under Jacko's guys
so he he was the individual that was you
know charged not only with running
training for everybody but specifically
vetting and mentoring the officers that
we're gonna be taking you know
deployable elements into combat so you
you are there
whole slew of reasons why I was eager to
have you on the podcast you've been
highly successful in multiple fields
you're well respected in multiple fields
certainly as a physical performance
specimen as the snake Gator put it sort
of irritatingly well-rounded and also
one hell of a nice guy which makes it
harder to find that bothersome I should
say but it's more of an end really
because I think it's so common you've
had some challenges since leaving the
military that I thought would be worth
getting into and I wanted to sort of
paint a picture of a lot of your
accomplishments first because I wanted
to establish that context but can can
you talk just and we'll of course dig
into a lot of the details but there been
a lot of highlights along the way about
what did you experience after the
military so I left active duty service
in 2013 after several deployments into
combat and everything was actually great
initially I left because of my family my
wife and I have been with each other
since high school and we had just had
our daughter in 2012 and that was for me
the catalyst that was ultimately gonna
you know help me make the decision to
choose my family and get out of the
military at that point so I transitioned
into the private sector initially in a
commercial real estate brokerage which
is you know super high-stress I wasn't
making any money whatsoever and and like
kind of the polar opposite of the SEAL
Teams in a minute of the military combat
units in general I was I was by myself
it was kind of a loan on an island
responsible for my own performance I
didn't have any teammates to look to
there was you know little to no
camaraderie and you know I kind of
carried on with that career until we
started the you know the current company
that that I'm running um you know
sunscreen company
and you know I'd say it was probably
2017 so four years elapsed before I
really I kind of had a moment I guess a
moment of clarity for myself where I
realized like I wasn't I just didn't
feel myself and you know it's difficult
at times to put it into words but I
remember my family was away on a trip
and I decided to stay home to work as
was the normal for me at that point and
it just kind of was feeling total apathy
I you know for things that I really find
passion and like climbing like zero
interest in it would find myself driving
to the gym and sitting in my truck for
like an hour but not wanting to to go in
and do something that I normally love
was becoming a little bit more aware of
kind of feelings of anger agitation
edginess in conversations with people I
you know I'd be in a normal kind of
one-on-one meeting with somebody and
with a really nice person and there's no
reason why I should be feeling angry or
or irritated and I would have to excuse
myself for meetings and didn't want to
interact with him and it was like 180
out for my normal personality I mean
like I yeah it's just very confused you
know I've always been a very even-keeled
nice person you know
don't look for conflict tried it you
know I walk away from fights and mean
normally if I I mean I was the kind that
was just very even keel and
even-tempered and I would just found
myself getting just very angry all the
time and I think he was bleeding into my
personal life with my my wife and my
kids you know just know he no ability to
cope with kind of distractions in the
house I just felt overwhelmed almost on
edge all the time and you know I got to
a point where I just didn't know how to
fix it you know so I you know I talked
to some people and just ask them if they
felt that
Wayne it's a former seals some buddies
of mine like guys that had exited the
military at that point and you know some
guys shared you know blood work and
testosterone count as you know
potentially that's an issue so I
remember going in and get a full getting
a full battery of blood work done and
you know my testosterone was fine it was
like very healthy and I remember kind of
having a one-on-one with the physician
that I was seeing and described
everything that I kind of described a
brief just now and and they they framed
it as depression and I said that's crazy
I'm not like I'm not depressed like I
just don't feel myself there has to be
something else wrong I'm not locking
myself in a dark room and I you know I'm
just it's not me and you know they they
were you know insistent in a way on
trying to put me on a serotonin drug on
an antidepressant oh that's all right
yeah correct and I you know it there's
nothing wrong with it but I just for me
personally I just didn't want to I I I
looked at it as like a band-aid fix I
just I didn't think it was gonna help me
get back to the person that I knew I was
so I just I tried to go out and find
other things something else to snap me
out of it besides like you know 40
ounces of coffee every single day
to try to like wake me up and actually
get me motivated at that point I mean
how long were you in that wandering
searching sort of coping but not having
returned to normal you like if it
doesn't have to be exact like for how
long were you on the search for for some
type of effects before you found
anything it helped you know it it
probably took me you know six months or
so yeah trying to I mean that it was
kind of a frustrating process of trying
to vet the blood work and
you know just see if it passed see if I
would just get back to normal and I
wasn't getting back to normal and I you
know I ultimately found something called
personalized repetitive transcranial
magnetic stimulation so it's a mouthful
I kind of stumbled upon it by accident I
had connected with a doctor in San Diego
that had been doing it for depression
and what is the acronym for that I mean
it's a form of T of s so it's PR TMS or
yeah just a very focused form of TMS you
know they did an EEG initially to kind
of look at your brainwave activity and
then treat frontal lobe with some
magnetic pulses to try to I guess like
retune the piano yeah and I talked to
some veterans actually talked to a
Marine and then a couple SEALs or former
seals you know off active duty this was
all kind of post active duty service
where it worked for him I mean they felt
like it it kind of snapped them back
into the person that they were so they
could get on a healthier track I mean
because ultimately the way I looked at
it as hey I just need something to make
me feel myself or I can sleep again
where I could start eating healthy again
or I can exercise or actually have a
passion to exercise again because those
are like the core foundational pillars
that have been I mean that's that's been
my foundation that's the reason you know
I'm able to stay healthy it's because of
my diet and sleep and exercise but I
just I need something that kind of might
help push me in that direction yeah it's
you know what you're describing
certainly I've never been in the
military but for people who've listened
to the podcast for a long time or read
any of the recent books I mean I've had
many extended bouts with certainly in
retrospect what I would call depression
and seems to be a family there seems to
be a software component I think what I
came preloaded with is that maybe a few
unusual
lines of code in it Maillard behavioral
piece and one of the one of the trickier
aspects for some people and this was
this has been true for me as well is
that if humans are kind of reward and
Punishment sort of incentive driven
machines if the reward that you received
from activities that were good for you
right in part the the joy of rock
climbing lets us say disappears right so
you have this like anhedonia this
inability to feel joy the normal kind of
feedback loops that that help encourage
you to follow these beneficial patterns
of behavior can kind of slip through
your fingers sure right because you're
just you're not getting the payoff
you're not getting the initial driving
you're not getting the payoff so the the
PR TMS is really interesting this is
something that actually came up not too
long ago very briefly with a physicist
who was on this podcast but we didn't
get into it because he had no personal
exposure to it was just very interested
in the science yeah
how how quickly did you see a response
to that it's crazy it was like immediate
for me so I'll I'll frame it I walked in
to this this office and I was in a
terrible mood like very antisocial just
at a very low spot and I actually was
very agitated with the guy who is kind
of bringing me in and asking me the
questions didn't even want to deal with
him and they didn't need G and and
snapped me down and I went through my
first battery of treatment and then I
guess the way that I and it I reacted to
it I've talked to other guys maybe that
didn't have the same type of reaction
but it was almost like a sense of being
caffeinated like when you drink you
haven't drank coffee for three weeks and
then all of a sudden you have you know a
double shot of espresso
I just feel like super on point and kind
of a way a wave of calm or like all
those feelings of agitation and anger
like subsided and it was
crazy like I did not expect that to
happen and I had to back it up I mean
after you know it would fade and then I
was going in pretty much five days a
week for like 30 minutes for six weeks
or so and then I was good for a while
probably for like six plus months okay
so the flywheel was spinning at that
point like you had enough momentum I
know this is metaphorically speaking but
at that point the durability you needed
to see you at five roughly say five
times per week for what do you say how
many ways six weeks six weeks and at
that point then the durability of effect
seemed to be about six months you did it
like it took effect and then immediately
you know I started sleeping better sleep
is the root of everything I think as it
relates to at least my experience with
this mental health though as I slept
better
I just felt better the apathy went away
I was more excited to go you know climb
more excited to spend time with my my
wife and my two kids and then it was
this positive feedback loop where it
just kind of kicked it jump-started me
into a track that I had been on but I
had just fallen off of yeah the the the
it strikes me that you needed the and in
a way the the reboot or the tuning sure
so that you could have a sort of
quote-unquote normal window within which
then you could make the decisions you
would have made normally absolutely that
make sense yeah like the the PR TMS
doesn't doesn't it doesn't make the
longer-term regular behavioral decisions
for you but helps it opens a window in
which you can make those decisions for
yourself yeah just true of a lot of some
of the treatments that I find more
interesting for this is that they're not
causal in and of themselves it's not one
and done but it opens in a window of
opportunity within which you can make
decisions with sort of your mind in a
better and
in a more focused place yeah since the
the you mentioned you mentioned sleep
and this is another variable that it has
just become over time more and more
interesting to me I mean certainly
you're no stranger to sleep deprivation
then we can certainly talk about that
and there were I mean long periods of
time where I used stimulants and
caffeine to self-medicate and it works
for a while or at least it makes you
feel like you're being productive for a
while what what types of systems or
habits have you built around sleep or
are there any other tools or resources
that you found helpful for sleep yeah so
trying to get sunlight in the morning I
you know going through the the TMS
battery I mean that was a very positive
habit that was formed because of that
treatment you know the doc said I need
you to get at least thirty minutes of
direct morning blue light exposure to
kind of kick your I guess your circadian
rhythm into into alignment so you
actually get tired you start to you know
produce the the chemicals internally
that you need to actually fall asleep
and get restful sleep so that was a big
one I I started I was cognizant of how
much time I did not spend in direct
sunlight you know with no glass in
between me and the and the blue light
mm-hm
you know once I started actually looking
at that I mean even make a point of
getting outside and and doing that I
don't know if this it has impacted like
a positive quality of sleep but I drink
a lot more water every morning I drank
32 ounces of water no fail sometimes I
don't want to but I do and I've become
more cognizant of just being more
hydrated
I've supplemented with vitamin D even
though I'm getting sunlight that seemed
to help
and then caffeine intake I mean I love
coffee it's I think it's it's
amazing performance-enhancing drug as it
relates to climbing it's probably the
best like best that I've found yeah like
drink a cup of coffee and you just focus
and you perform well I've gotten into a
habit of not drinking it later in the
day not drinking it at 7 or 8 o'clock at
night
well I was gonna say I don't wanna take
us totally off the rails but one of the
things you mentioned during lunch that I
never would have thought of in a million
years you're talking about heading out
to climb in the middle of the night with
headlamps sure and I was like what why
would you do that and you're talking
about the temperature and how your skin
is just tighter more resilient you can
climb more effectively way better than a
cold yeah so that I can I can see that
being maybe not the ideal time to down a
whole lot of coffee and I definitely had
fallen victim to drinking coffee at 11
o'clock at night you know I want to
we're gonna keep going so you can think
of any other things that might have
helped as it relates to sleep but the
sun exposure first thing in the morning
and not having anything between you even
if it is say panes of glass sure is
something that a number of guests on
this podcast have mentioned I only
thought about it right now it's been a
while as being instrumental in
completely changing the trajectory of
their physical life like Rick Rubin
legendary music producer has very
similar practice like least 20 or 30
minutes of direct sunlight every morning
that doesn't mean it has to be sunny out
also like he can be honest it just means
being outside and shortly thereafter
along with other things I mean he lost a
hundred plus pounds right but that was
sort of the the first domino which was a
daily ingredient first thing upon waking
that made a huge difference when do you
stop drinking caffeine during the day
have what are the rules you've set for
yourself so it's been recently it's been
better I actually have fallen into
drinking butter coffee mmm first thing
in the morning and I don't drink coffee
after that so I might have that at like
8 a.m. and then
it kind of has forced it like an
intermittent fast like a short-term fast
where I feel focused throughout the day
and don't need to drink coffee in the
afternoon I would feel you know prior to
that I would feel kind of this afternoon
like energy dump and like feel like I
need to drink more coffee to go climb or
do something you know me be a productive
so that's helped so I try to cut it out
completely you know after my morning
coffee I'm not touching it again
yeah it's I've noticed
I think this caffeine piece is really
key for a lot of people including myself
and I have noticed for instance there
are certain things we're going to talk
about this that are harbingers or like
the canary in the coalmine as it relates
to possible periods of depression or
apathy or and I don't need all these
things and that for me at least the
caffeine can precipitate a lot of it
right because if for whatever reason I'm
consuming too much caffeine too late not
too high quantity what does that start
to affect it starts to affect sleep even
if you're in bed for eight hours you may
have very disrupted sleep and then it
becomes this vicious cycle that tends to
exacerbate all of the things that you're
trying to avoid yeah right and so so for
me also combining say extended exercise
at some point and say the afternoon
gives me a break from my habitual
caffeine consumption window right you
know and if that makes any sense
because as as a as someone who's
effectively worked by himself which i
think is problematical a lot of ways
psychologically for 20 plus years like
okay well I go to a coffee shop go to a
restaurant and a lot of these places
it's an endless cup of coffee or it's
and endless we yeah you end up it's like
okay over a handful of hours at least I
would I drink like 15 cups of iced tea
or like seven cups of coffee yeah yeah
you know I realized at one point I went
to this I did this this retreat at one
point where I had
I'll down my coffee and get to the point
where I wouldn't have these withdrawal
headaches then I came back and just went
straight back into my normal routine of
like inadvertently consuming six cups in
a day and I thought to myself holy [ __ ]
because this was this my normal right no
wonder I was so like anxious that's so
much trouble sleeping and so for me this
is a long roundabout way of saying you
can you can use all the meditation apps
and take all the supplements and do all
these things to decrease your anxiety
can improve your sleep or you can just
have like one or two cups of coffee in
the morning yeah and not have sex yeah
much rather perform a little bit like at
a lower intensity you know in the
evening when I work out yeah then suffer
the consequences of having caffeine that
late in the day yeah a lot of I like I
mentioned earlier I'm not a foreign
military but I've spent a lot of time
with foreign military and a lot of guys
seem to experience this tired and wired
phenomenon where they'll they'll try to
go to sleep and then suddenly they're
wide awake and they have this surge of
cortisol like late at night as opposed
to early in the morning when you're
evolutionarily designed to have this
surge of cortisol so that it liberates
glycogen you get a spike in blood
glucose and then BAM you're awake and
some folks at and I don't know if you've
ever bumped into Kirk parsley he does a
lot of work with guys it's liquor you do
yes so he's worked on some interesting
concoctions sleep and you know
phosphatidylserine is not a replacement
for cutting back on your caffeine
consumption but can help blunt that
cortisol release yeah
prior to sleep anything else that you
found helpful for for for sleep or rest
so funny enough I I tried a supplement a
magnesium supplement called call yeah it
actually worked for me very well I mean
like I would drink it at in the evening
and I would start to yawn you know and
actually feel like I wanted to
and that was such like Oh before I kind
of went through that initial battery of
TMS and kind of getting myself back on
track
like I couldn't think I I couldn't
recall the last time I like I actually
yawned and wanted to go to sleep like I
would force myself to go to sleep
because that was just what I was
supposed to do when it was really dark
and my wife was in bed and the kids are
asleep you know and I'm sitting there
wired like working or just laying on the
couch staring at the ceiling no so it
was yeah pretty interesting I mean the
TMS definitely liked it I'm like man I'm
tired him and then I turned to that
magnesium supplement and it actually
yeah I thought that was pretty helpful
it's one of the biggest bang for your
buck supplements for sleep that I've
come across and there are a million
variations of magnesium three and eight
citrate and it was there there a million
different varieties but the calm
products pretty good does have a strong
flavor to it
generally the raspberry lemonade and
yeah it's got a strong flavor to it but
it it really does help with sleep yeah
and for people who are struggling that
that's potentially worth experiment with
I will add a caveat to that then maybe
I'm speaking specifically to you my
fellow Americans more is not necessarily
better with magnesium and if you overdo
magnesium there's a increased likelihood
of disaster pants so just follow your
label directions so you don't foul out
would be a pro tip what other rules or
practices have you built into your life
to either keep well let me ask ask the
question so you go through the PR TMS
you instill these habits have you had
any recurring bouts of challenges with
what you might term apathy or depression
or is that gone away entirely yeah
absolutely you have that yeah it's not
an end-all be-all there's no magic pill
yeah you know you know what has been I
guess the most impactful part of that
whole experience you know beyond the
treatment and I Pro
even more so than the treatment you know
the first you know period of time that I
went in for the TMS I ran into like
three or four guys that I hadn't seen in
years from the teams like in the waiting
room you know in a totally discreet
building like he would never run into
anybody there
yeah right it's nothing there wasn't a
Starbucks in the lobby exactly in the
lobby conversations with you know you
know my boys got guys that I I served
with and the teams I hadn't seen him
forever was killer I mean like people we
were in a place I mean I think part of
it is like it we have mutual respect and
trust and loyalty to each other and you
were in kind of a safe place with safe
people to share like very very similar
experiences and like that shared
experience and just talking about it was
probably the most like beneficial part
of the entire thing
um because I had I had three or four
guys immediately that I could reach out
to and talk to as soon as I felt myself
starting to slip you know you know I
think and it also kind of served for me
as a it was kind of that shove in in the
back to open up to some people that that
I was close to you that weren't you know
people I served with in the military you
know my my wife who actually opened up
to me and told me that you know this
wasn't something new she had noticed it
for years and it was probably a point of
contention and in trouble in our
marriage from time to time that we'd had
to struggle through that if you don't
mind I mean because of people listening
they're all the people are listening to
us they're gonna be people are like
listening with the fascination of
watching like an exotic animal in a in a
zoo or they're like I've never
experienced that this is interesting
then they're the people who've
experienced it directly yeah in some way
whether it's just down periods extended
funks or clinical depression or really
extreme varieties of that which which we
can talk about and then you have the
people who may have not experienced
directly but they've
been affected because someone close
friend a family member what was if you
know if you don't mind me asking me what
was it like for your wife having this
experience with you
I think for Vike here I'm being with you
while you're going through it yeah I
think probably very frustrating for her
for years
I think probably a lot of our arguments
and in not you know we love each other
we have a very healthy marriage and you
know we have two wonderful kids but you
know we got you get into arguments right
and I think I you know there was
probably a lot of frustration because
she saw me differently I mean she even
you know her own words at times were you
know you're you're different you you're
not the same person that I married and I
think part of that was probably the
separation right I mean there was long
periods of time both in training and
then deployment or we just didn't see
each other and you do that repeatedly I
mean I did it three times there's guys
you know from our community and other
branches as a service that have done it
you know 12 times 15 times and you know
you know I thought I knew myself and I'm
like I didn't change I'm the same person
but she kind of watched this and was
just frustrated because it was like I
you know I couldn't see it I couldn't
look at myself in the mirror and see the
changes that she saw because she would
be removed from me first you know eight
months and then all of a sudden you know
it's like it's like not seeing your your
six month old for two months and the
little guy or girl has changed
considerably right because you were
removed from them and they went through
this this period of transition or change
so I mean I mean I actually have I feel
terrible that she had to go through it
and I didn't recognize and I think part
of it is I just probably was in denial I
mean this is probably another whole
channel of conversation but I mean I I
think society especially the community
that I came from you know being in the
military and the SEAL Teams like
I saw this weakness right I didn't want
to think about like I don't have a
mental health issue I mean in society
it's like it's painted in such a
negative light you know that you know I
did everything in my power to ignore it
or be just pretend that it wasn't wasn't
there okay don't be not be honest with
myself because I don't want to show
weakness yeah totally and and it's it's
worth noting that this is not a small
issue whether and by by this we could be
talking about depression would we be
talking about sort of mental health
related problems and challenges in say
the US as a whole certainly globally but
I'm more familiar with the the sort of
state of affairs in the US or it's
something like 20 to 23 as is the range
I hear most often veterans commit
suicide is it daily so I'm a far more
loss of life sort of after service then
during yeah arrabal active service and
you know last year for if we're taking
it outside of the if we're taking it
outside of the context of the military
but still there's a huge overlap because
a lot of returning vets are prescribed
say synthetic opioids and so on I mean
if more synthetic opioid related deaths
I want to say in 2017 than all the
casualties of the Vietnam War
yeah right when you put in perspective
and these are common issues there's very
common but the illusion of the the
perceptual illusion that's created
because relatively speaking few people
talk about it publicly right is that you
if you're feeling depressed or film the
condition that is stigmatized you feel
maybe uniquely flawed or you don't want
to admit that it's an issue because you
think you're one in a thousand people
you know who would possibly have it and
it's just not the case go get a pill and
fix it so you don't have to talk to
anybody about it yeah and you know in
some cases the you know the medications
can be incredibly incredibly helpful
sure but
at the same time I think that it's it's
one tool and the toolkit right and a lot
of people will be non-responders or very
short-term responders to some of the
medications some of these alternative
tools are I think very very important so
what are some of the signs because and
we were chatting about this last night
where as saying you know in my mind as
someone who's seen family members really
affected by say depression specifically
and Friends certainly I mean my best
friends just again to broaden things a
little bit so people realize the
pervasiveness of this it's like one of
my best friends in high school offed
himself by the time before he graduated
from college yeah best friend from Long
Island died of a fentanyl overdose you
know aunt recently died of alcohol and
percocet about a year ago overdose and
two of my best friends in college killed
themselves with a few years of
graduation and these are these are like
fancy I went to some fancy schools like
that's not that shouldn't happen and so
it shows that like these issues also
like do not discriminate right because
in part I think they're a byproduct of
the human condition but also a lot of
modern societal factors right so it's
like these things don't care how fast
you are they don't care how athletic you
are they don't care how much or how
little money you have they don't care
what race you are and that's that's
that's partners and I care so much and
to wind back to what I was going to ask
because I think it's important and as as
context last night
I was saying that there are in terms of
people who are directly affected by this
there are people who will end up at some
point
experiencing say depression or chronic
anxiety or something that just feels off
right they don't feel themselves and
they don't know how to get back yep to
themselves but there are the people who
haven't yet experienced that there are
the people who are in the middle of it
sort of in the trough of sorrow like
their this this period of maybe despair
despondency apathy
and then there are the people who are in
a good place currently but who dip in
and out right so you mentioned like when
you start to see sore symptoms
yeah or like the telltale signs like a
storm is brewing on the horizon
what are those for you well so I think
that the people that have experienced it
and are willing to talk about it and
share maybe even unsolicited you know
with people that they know care about
trust I mean I think that's one of the
biggest things that we can do to kind of
help those people that maybe are ashamed
of it um see it as weakness yeah because
it mean that for me I mean it helped me
open up and I've had some pretty gnarly
people from the teams that I look up to
open up you know that are having that
kind of shared conversation of
experiences um so I think that's that
would be a huge part of it is just you
know people that are brave enough to
share it and not feel like they're
exposing themselves as somebody that's
weak is is a big thing you know the the
symptoms are different for so many for
different people right for you so for me
personally you know frustration and
agitation are probably like the two core
kind of telltale signs so for instance
Tim and you and I would be talking to
each other yeah and you might not even
be talking over me or interrupting me
but I I will stop almost as if I'm like
I'm irritated that I'm not getting my
thoughts out fast enough I'm not I can't
kind of finish my train of thought and
and I become visibly agitated and
irritated and my you know my
brother-in-law that spends a lot of time
with me at our company he's he's been
really good at picking up on it I mean
he's actually will be in conversations
where I know I'm not feeling myself and
I might not even I might know I'll say
I'm not feeling myself I have not even
realized that I'm falling into a bad
spot and he'll pull me aside after a
meeting I'll say hey man I
just you you should take off just relax
like I got your back like you don't have
to be here right now
mmm and and I think it's because he's
recognized that pattern yeah it's gonna
be people that are closest to you right
yeah and you know I you you remind me of
something just because I feel like we
have some maybe shared DNA might be put
on them I mean as a species obviously
but the the folio Manning is like I am
NOT able to do one-tenth of the things
you're able to do but I do have shared
history in terms of experience with
these things right
and if having a teammate like your
brother in law to flag things when your
self-awareness is kind of dimmed is
really valuable and you don't have to
wait for like a guardian angel to fall
out of the sky you can go to your
friends and say look I just want to if I
could ask you for a favor I'm I will I
will not get upset maybe I will a little
bit but I'm giving you permission in
advance because you're my friend like if
you spot any of these things or you
think I'm really not being myself please
bring it up yeah I like encourage the
people closest to you to do that because
they will you know sort of like having
of someone who's who's specially trained
to diagnose certain conditions that you
are unable to see yourself yeah it's
very very valuable to have have those
people so frustration and agitation the
biggest ones for sure yeah so for me
just for people out there I mean this is
and this is something I've had to learn
over time it's like many many let's just
say at least three or four days of
continuous fatigue even though I appear
to be getting enough sleep
yeah is another one and the the the
unhelpful response to that is just to
say [ __ ] it I'm gonna double down let me
have Cathy for triple espressos and just
power through whatever this is which
magnifies the problem your sleeps
wonderful than your sleeps fantastic
it gets a lot better that's that's
sarcasm so kind of flagging that and
realizing the world's not gonna end if
you need to take like three hours to go
for a long walk or two what what I will
usually try to do is kind of work up one
historical mistake that I've made is if
we're looking at say Maslow's hierarchy
of needs right you've got physical
safety shelter and all the stuff down at
the bottom food and then it goes all the
way up to self-actualization I found it
often unhelpful to try to sit down with
a journal and figure out like the
existential underpinnings of why I'm
feeling off it's like no stupid thank
sunlight right simple simple stuff right
like sunlight maybe you get too grumpy
if you try what everyone seems to be
doing like intermittent fasting so you
should probably maybe should just have a
meal when you wake up yeah yeah like
let's like rather than trying to sort of
unravel some Gordian knot of like
philosophical complexity in your head
what you think is going to solve your
problems we just need like a handful of
macadamia nuts and a cold [ __ ] shower
and like that's actually get up the next
day
yeah and creating space for that right
in response to the fatigue but having
that as a red flag and also trying to
train people around me or ask people
around me whether it's family member is
a girlfriend boyfriend whatever to flag
that what I think it brings up the the
importance of a strong community you
know you know not it might not just be
your spouse or your you know your family
member or your friend like finding
community in something else is a great
kind of second line of defense yeah or
even first line of defense I mean I
spend a lot of time you know climbing
and training with people I probably
spend as much time with them as I do at
work it you know periods in my life and
these are these are I should also
suggest to folks because I've I've
volunteered a lot you know historically
that's just been like okay if it's my
problem it's my problem I don't want to
be a burden
I also don't wanna be embarrassed so I'm
gonna isolate and sort this out myself
sometimes that works a lot of the time
it backfires and just exacerbates the
problem so you can when you're talking
about support systems I I know because I
have been this person that a lot of
people out there like that's great but
what if like I live by myself I work by
myself I don't have that support
structure you can actually sort of rent
friends and support structure what I
mean by that is that as one example
humans are weird creatures and like
we're not all rational actors even
though a lot of economists would love us
to be like rational robots like doing
our various things it's often not the
case and humans for instance will work a
lot harder to avoid losing a hundred
dollars then they will turn hundred
dollars right and so you can this is
something I've done which is pre-booked
group activities whether that's like a
dance class or a Brazilian jiu-jitsu
class or fill in the blank like some
type of group activity pay for it in
advance so that you're gonna feel like a
schmuck if and you're gonna have that
loss aversion and you've just you've
you've stacked the deck in such a way
that makes it more likely you will not
self isolate right and and then you can
create that structure if you don't have
it plug and play ready to go if you
don't have like five people around you
who are immediately available you can it
is something you can engineer so yeah
what I'm trying to say I mean I'm lucky
in that regard I mean I have as people
that I've surrounded myself with that
that love me and care about me and I
know that's not the case with everybody
so now nonetheless you were at one point
with the commercial real estate
it sounds like sort of lone wolfing it
sure and even though you had family and
so on you felt isolated yeah at times
yes it I saluted myself too
yeah so have you corrected that what
what steps have you taken to correct
that well I mean I think at the time I
was rash
lysing that i had to work really hard to
take care of my family so i I was
literally I left the military to be with
my family yet I was ripping myself away
from my family under the the guise of
I'm I'm doing this for you guys right so
I think it was it was having to man up
and realize that it's a cop-out you know
I was pretending like I was it was
easier for me just to focus on work yeah
then to invest in my family invest in
those people that care about me so this
this makes me want to return to a
question that I would imagine some
people have we're listening to this
which is why did you suddenly have this
this apathy and this depression like
what were the causal factors like we're
talking about how to address it but like
why did you go from having none of that
as part of your history to suddenly
having that yeah experience like what do
you think contributed to that so I mean
it's a multiple factor situation right I
you know you can point to kind of the
distress right chronic sleep deprivation
during military service I I did have
exposure to blast and I was in - ided
strikes like vehicle ided strikes in
2006 and then you know as a member of a
CO element overseas we were explosively
breaching so you know that concussive
element may have had something to do
with kind of this later didn't in terms
of like TBI like traumatic brain injury
yeah I mean I think that all that stuff
I mean the a mean lack of sleep is a TBI
right of itself you don't have to be
exposed to an ie D blast of a TBI I mean
that um just repetitive small
concussions
I mean pro athletes football players
hockey players you know that have CTE
which is a form of TBI from repeated
concussions
you know both mass major and minor yeah
right so I think that that all
contributed to it um but I think the
thing the most common
thread that I've picked up in
conversations with other buddies of mine
that have transitioned and I've felt
similar things is this this kind of loss
of community like loss of brotherhood
like loss of purpose you know losing the
identity of being a member of this team
of people that love and care about you
and have your back no matter what
and I mean we'll give their life you
know to protect yours it's like really
heavy right I mean that's the reason you
know when we lose a guy overseas I mean
I'm yeah I mean I give like a physical
reaction to it is like the the the pure
like I call it love now and I never used
the word love either Tim like I mean
most of my life until recently I I just
rarely used the word love never told
guys I served with that I love them and
I've tried to make a point of saying
that more often because like you have
this deep sense of love and then all of
a sudden I transition and it's gone yeah
and I don't have any I mean I you know
and my wife and I have my kids and I
love them and they love me but like I
don't have that Brotherhood anymore and
and I've talked to more guys that like
they go you go through this transition
whether it's at retirement or five years
into a career in the military and and
you miss it it's like this void in your
life and I think the bad is probably
it's probably one of the biggest
contributing factors to kind of me going
through this this frame it as depression
or whatever but yeah I mean I think I
you know it's taken it's taken some
years of being kind of introspective and
unders trying to like ask the why don't
get to that conclusion but you know it's
surrounding myself with more people that
I do consider like one of my boys like a
brother that I love and they love me um
you know both at work any kind of my new
life in this you know in pursuit of
entrepreneurship
but also kind of reconnecting with guys
that I served with I mean I probably
reconnected with more bodies from the
teams in the last two years that I had
done in the four years prior to that
this is worth spending a little bit of
time on one of the things that has
helped me quite a bit when I'm feeling
exceeding the storm on the horizon like
spotting some of the symptoms or having
people point out the symptoms to me or
the eshton's had symptoms like the
tell-tale signs and that that something
might be coming which you can sometimes
kind of head off at the pass I mean it's
not inevitable that when you spot
something coming it has to arrive in
full at least in my experience and I
haven't had I would say like I used to
have probably two major extended
depressive episodes a year something
like that and I haven't had anything
that I would characterize as a major
depressive episode my last four or five
years so like there are there are levers
you can pull and systems you can put in
place that work really effectively and
you know one of them for me and this
ties back to what you were just saying
has been when I'm unsure of and I'm
looking at it there's slightly different
lens but practically I think they're
very similar when I'm unsure of what to
do to get myself back to normal
reaching out to old friends or mentors
to say thanks for something right it's
like somebody from college you were
really close to or someone from high
school you were really close to
childhood a former coach a former
professor whoever it is it could be
anyone
a family member you haven't talked to in
a few years right and just reaching out
to reconnect and say thanks for some
thing or to tell them that you love them
or whatever it might be has a real
retelling effect yeah that is is really
grounding and the fact of the matter is
like what we take to be normal right now
in most modern industrialized countries
and I'm not saying there hasn't been a
lot of good that has come
globalization industrialization I mean
if you read Steven Pinker's I think it's
angels of our better nature
a lot of this becomes clear like we are
we are living in some respects in a
golden age with respect to all sorts of
societal problems and forms of violence
and so on there were much more prevalent
pretty much every historical era up to
now that having been said the nature of
like hominid cohabitation has sort of
been fractured in the last century to a
point where then what we take as normal
which is this default isolation and at
most nuclear family sort of cohabitation
is is pretty abnormal like it's sort of
like the the last page in a 700 page
book that chronicles human evolution
right and so you if you want to take so
in a sense like the feeling depressed or
isolated or anxious is a very natural
response to unnatural sort of recent
developments yeah and if you want to
counteract that you need to develop
these countermeasures right and be more
proactive in creating what a thousand
years ago would have just kind of fallen
into your lap because it would have been
something you experienced in your daily
course of living so reaching out to
people for when I start feeling myself
dip whatever however that manifests very
often I'll start reaching out to people
I haven't connected with in a long time
to say thank you or express my gratitude
or love to them in some way and it's
it's remarkable how much of an effect
that has and how quickly the effect I
consented couldn't agree with you more I
mean I literally I've done that recently
with a couple close friends guys that I
was close with you know while I was on
active duty I served with overseas then
his head and talked to him in years
I mean seven years and then all of a
sudden you know actually having the
courage to reach out to them knowing
that you know if they really do care
about
and love you they're not gonna judge you
for the lapse in communication though
and that's I don't think I've in a in
not a single instance that I've reached
out to somebody that I'd lost contact
with had they ever kind of received me
poorly yeah and it's awesome right I
mean I feel like we didn't skip a beat
you got another friend you can actually
show gratitude for who they are and what
they did for you yeah it's pretty it's
pretty badass I mean it's awesome
so speaking of badass said part of the
reason because I was like I was I was
eager and excited to have you on the
podcast as you know a I'd heard a lot
about you just as from the perspective
of like badass [ __ ] II which I
found interesting in and of itself as I
as a u.s. high performer but the the
combination of that and the openness to
come on and talk about these things I
really wanted to magnify through the
podcast because this is not uncommon and
you know people who might hear this are
I think custom to as I have been as we
all are to seeing sort of the Instagram
highlight magazine cover version of
other people's lives so you hear the
stories and it seems like these titans
of industry these Navy SEALs these fill
in the blank that you might aspire to be
more like have none of the challenges
that you're experience that you're
experiencing yourself and so it can
become very easy to just assume that
you're some broken toy without a fix
that can leave to lead to a lot of
despair and ultimately suicide and all
sorts of awful things and like you said
in in certain communities whether that's
yours or I have friends in law
enforcement mm-hmm
within which they're effectively not
allowed to have mental illness or
challenges with mental health yeah
these are in some respects like the the
exact places where people feel least
likely to or open to talking about these
things is where they need to talk about
them the most absolutely right and so I
wanted this to you know not not just
provide you know an example of a very
high performer who's willing to talk
about these things openly but also to
give people some tools and approaches
yeah which which you've developed and
found which which I have also over time
it's taken me an embarrassingly long
time to [ __ ] figure it out but I'm
hoping to sure you know who having you
on will help kind of shorten the
learning curve or steep and learning
curve for a lot of people what would you
say to folks out there men and women
because certainly this does not these
these types of challenges do not care
about gender or anything else no well
what would you say to someone who's
really struggling right now is there
anything else that there anything that
comes to mind offhand that you would you
would say oh I would say you're not
alone well don't you're not weak you're
not broken you're not different
you know I've I've been through some
terrible times dealing with this and I'm
dealing with it I'm not ignoring it you
know I'm confronting it face on just
like I would anything else yeah and I'm
not broken like I feel very effective in
what I do day to day and I would say you
know don't don't fall victim to kind of
the definition that everybody in society
has put on you know mental illness is it
being a badge of weakness because it
absolutely isn't yeah it just is yeah I
do you know it's it's it's one of those
phrases also that it's just could use a
rebrand and great in the sense so like
mental illness just sounds so terribad
it's like oh he's fallen fallen ill with
about of melancholia or whatever it's
like oh wow what's wrong with that
[ __ ] and whereas it's like a in some
respects I mean you have mental illness
right be of mental injury too so there
can be
and a lot of people experience these
whether it's single acute events the
kind of that have a traumatic impact and
and and lead their life to take a
90-degree turn or as you as you put it
there can be these these repeated
exposures to different types of
stressors whether it's traumatic brain
injury or sleep deprivation or otherwise
and in in some respects I mean it's we
tend to think about
I think the like mental illness in a
very abstract way in so much as it's
like oh there's something wrong with our
mind and therefore it is somehow less
legitimate than like an Achilles tendon
sprain the fact that matter is like the
brains in Oregon it can be damaged very
easily yeah things like dehydration
dramatically increased the likelihood of
some type of sort of neuroanatomical
injury I can say from firsthand
experience having done lots of stupid
things as a wrestler cutting tons of
weight and similarly it's like you
wouldn't be ashamed to go to an
orthopedist to look at like plantar
fasciitis right chronic right or acute
like Achilles tendon tear like no you
wouldn't have any shame associated with
that and similarly I'm not saying
flippantly that you should just brush
aside any concerns about how things will
be perceived because I think that's over
time this will become a broader
conversation as more and more people
come out of the closet so to speak with
something that I think is is actually
the the rule not the exception yeah
certainly that like these are these are
experiences and conditions and injuries
that can be rehabbed and they can be
prehab also right so you can do things
to fix it you can also do things that
make you more resilient and less
susceptible yep well yeah I'd say this
to like these issues that we've been
talking about I almost look at them as
like the currency that I you know I paid
I'm paying for the growth that came out
of all these experiences right
people people talk about post-traumatic
growth I am so deeply thankful for the
experiences that I had in service to
this country and I know it's struggled
to find another guy that served guy or
gal that served in combat in defense of
this nation that doesn't feel like they
are a better version of themselves
because of it and this is a this is a
small price to pay
you know I'll deal with it it's just
like the pro athlete that has you know
some jacked up knees and shoulders now
but do you think that they would trade
all those days of glory competing in
athletics because they knew that they
were gonna be injured do you think that
they would like give up all of that
glory for you know maybe healthier knees
and shoulders I guarantee you every
single one would be like now I'm glad
you know what I'll deal with it you know
the experience that I was able to draw
and the growth personally that I was
able to pull from those experiences it's
you can't put a price tag on it
yeah and that's true also for I think
it's personally I think it's very true
for sort of less obvious examples it by
obvious I mean less high-profile
examples right it's a I think that if I
look at for instance now that I know
them as adults like some of the mentors
who have the biggest impacts on my life
I mean really kind of a fork in the road
they let me down a much much better path
type of impact on my life and I look at
the teachers and I look at the writers
now that I've gotten to know some of
these writers personally I've realized
how the their their superpowers in some
sense were forged like from a lot of
their greatest pain and there's dramatic
experiences and like without those they
would have been unable to develop the
things that made them who they are and
enabled them to actually put a positive
dent in the world which does not mean
you have to impact ten million people or
100 million people or a thousand people
it could just be like your kid
yeah which is there's no just right
that's a big deal that you're like your
gifts are and I'm not other people have
said this to me Graham Duncan on the
podcast and quite a few people have said
this so I'm fortunate that you know
people speak quite openly in this forum
that like your your your greatest
talents or right the right next to your
greatest pain like they're not
diametrically opposed they're actually
integrally related right and so one
thing I've tried very hard to do also is
to look at some of these experiences
make okay like I've had some very very
dark periods how can I make that part
not divorce it from myself not hate that
part of myself not try to
compartmentalize it and lock it away
because I will say you're going to deal
with it whether you deal with it or not
what I mean by that is like you can
choose to sort of look at it and and in
the light and incorporate it and sort of
thank it in some ways for what it's
taught you and enabled you to endure so
that you can help other people to do the
same or you can lock it away and you can
have it manifested in the anger and
frustration or these right these you can
have it kind of seep out through the
cracks and deal with it in a much more
complicated way so so for me it's it's
in it it is in a way putting on not
necessarily rose-colored glasses but
looking for the silver lining and trying
to look for like the gift that is
attached to the pain absolutely
adversity tempers yeah right I mean yeah
exactly my some of my greatest lessons
learned both in the military and outside
of the military have come through you
know pretty serious failures yeah I mean
I if you asked me about the the number
of times that I did great things yeah as
a leader in the teams sometimes it's
tough to even come like I have to
actually like think very hard about like
the good things I mean I because like
the things that resonate with me are
those times that I I screwed something
up yeah and I you know I got a pretty
stern talking-to from
you know the troop commander that was in
charge of me and I fixed it and I moved
on and I grew from the experience yeah
what other what other habits or tools or
practices have you you incorporated that
have become more important to you or
you've recognized is more important
after having these various experiences
and realizations aside from the the PRT
MS um I think learning to assume not
just share my you know you know if I'm
feeling off sharing that with people I
think just being more open and
communicating
you know grief then I've I've kind of
like swallowed and kept kind of hidden
away I think I've have lost a bunch of
friends in in combat but I've also lost
some very close family members my
younger brother father and I never never
talked about it I never talked about
them and recently I've been in
situations I probably opening up to
people and becoming more you know honest
and vulnerable with people I've shared
that a lot more openly and it's been one
of the best medicines that I found I
mean it's almost it's liberating you
know talking about grief has been
something that's unlocked a lot of
happiness for me how did you decide to
do that I mean was there a particular
conversation or a particular day when
you're like [ __ ] it I'm gonna talk about
this I mean what if you if you did it
for so long right like what was what was
the catalyst I was like so to be frank I
was kind of forced into it I belong to
entrepreneurs organizations San Diego
chapter and I joined about a year and a
half ago and put into a forum like seven
eight guys or gals all entrepreneurs and
we went on a retreat and in that
construct which is you know all in
confidence you know sharing top and
bottom 5% of your life you know I shared
what we you call lifeline so it's an
exercise where basically you walk from
like kind of the beginning of your life
to where you are present day and it
almost looks like like a cardiogram
right it's like a seismic you know sure
yeah so I so I was kind of forced into
talking about like you know some very
shitty times in my life and talking
about losing guys overseas and riding
home with a bunch of casements and you
know putting myself and nah you know
putting myself and people like like seen
myself in in some of the guys that died
cuz they were any you know very similar
places in life you know compared to me
at the time that we lost them you know
it was like the most therapeutic
experience being forced to share that
and in having you know uncomfortable to
say the least and I'm not a very
emotional person but but it was like the
doing that for being forced into that
exercise has made it so much easier to
share like more openly with people it's
like every time I talk about it it gets
a little bit easier yeah and to the
point where that now I can actually talk
about it and I'm not a mess like I
remember the first time I talked about
there's a guy his name was Brendan
Looney that we lost in a Black Hawk
helicopter crash in September of 2010 in
Afghanistan and he was killed with along
with eight other u.s. servicemembers and
every time I talked and I didn't talk
about it for a long time but I like I
saw a lot I saw myself at Brendan
Brendan was newly married I was newly
married young Naval Academy officer I
went to the same school and I you know I
flew home with with him when we he went
back to Baltimore and spent time with
his family and got to see you know his
high school which was a private Catholic
High School which I went to a private
Catholic High School was just like like
it resonated it would be an impact of me
tremendously and I don't know I've lost
other guys that I've been close to but
for some reason it was like I was almost
like watching your own funeral which was
super heavy and I just refrain from
talking about it and you know the first
time I did start to share and I talked
about it it's just a complete mess like
like snot and like I couldn't stop
crying and like it's just like I've
never I haven't been like that I mean
probably the last time I was like that
is like at my brother's funeral
and I find myself now being able to I
mean to talk about it I to talk about it
in this forum like it's almost like I'm
comfortable like I like like I've I'm
dealing with it instead of just kind of
keeping it suppressed then it's I think
I'm better for it you know and actually
talking about it I keep you know his
memory alive and I think it's the it's
the it's the biggest show of gratitude
that you can you can give to somebody
that you know that has sacrificed at
that level is to keep the memory alive
by telling their story and talking about
how much they meant to you and you've
made so many really important points I'd
love to just repeat a few of them
because I want I want people to remember
at least a few things that you just
mentioned one is that the expression of
grief how the expression of grief has
given you access to greater joy the
happiness just so I don't sound like I'm
interviewing myself this entire
conversation I'm not going to get too
deep into it but I
didn't there was a period of like 2530
years when I did not cry at all funerals
you name it no crying until about five
or six years ago and accessing that you
know what I always considered to be a
negative or weak or fill-in-the-blank
bad adjective emotion has unlocked so
much of the top line in terms of the
peaks of what you would consider
positive emotions yeah it's it's been
this entirely unexpected for me
consequence yeah of that and if people
are entrepreneurs me that seems like
reason just that exercise alone seems
like reason enough to join the yellow
and I certainly have no dog in that
fight I'm not but I have I do know a lot
of people who have really really
benefited from the forum structure yeah
and for a lot it seems like for a lot of
people who join something like that and
I'm sure there are many different
alternatives out there I just happen to
have been told of the EO forum structure
a fair a number of times for a lot of
folks it seems like it's the first time
when a they have the sort of comfort of
speaking to a small group of people on a
similar path with in confidence sure
right they explicit you come up a
detective yeah explicit confidence and
second where they also feel a beneficial
level of peer pressure to be fully
transparent yeah right and that's an
incredible combo it's like competitive
right yeah the deeper one guy goes you
want to like one-up him yeah you know
deeper than that gives you permission
yeah it gives you permission and there
there's a book for people who maybe
struggle with this there's a book that I
I have only read bits and pieces of but
I know that it's been tremendously
helpful to a few friends of mine who
have lost family members and had
perhaps not come from highly expressive
environments and have really struggled
to kind of metabolize the experience on
grief in grieving it's a very generic
boring sounding title but exceptionally
well developed book for people who may
want to explore this so that that was
the catalyst that's your guess sometimes
you need a bunch of people that didn't
serve in the military and it took them
to kind of force me to to deal with
things that you know yeah I have been
suppressing for a very long time yeah
yeah that's that's really powerful yeah
I think we've we've covered so much and
I mean that there there are all sorts of
other things we could talk about now I
mean we are going to mention and I'll
mention a number of foundations that
that both you know active former
military non military can look to if
they want to support sort of you and
your brothers and sisters both within
steel community outside of the steel
community so what we'll talk about that
there any other I want to mention a few
sort of adjunct therapies that I think
are worth researching for people who are
either affected directly or affected by
loved ones who struggle with some of
these these challenges we've discussed
but any any other resources or
suggestions books you found helpful if
any really anything at all that in in
terms of tools you would you would
recommend to folks it doesn't have to be
fancy it could be something very simple
like the simple but underestimated and
its impact like the 23 minutes a son
yeah right no I mean so you know we I
know we started with with rock climbing
yeah and that's a big part of my life I
mean I have a true passion for it it
makes me it gets me excited like I would
much rather do that then go you know on
a European vacation you know staying at
the best hotels like I'd rather go sleep
in the dirt and go
there someplace you know I think it's
just finding a finding something outside
of family and or work that you're stoked
on yeah um so you know climbing is a big
part of my life I will say this year a
good friend of mine David Wells who is a
former pitcher threw a perfect game as a
Yankee nicknames boomer he's a
phenomenal human being he has been there
for me through thick and thin you know
going through some very low points
you know he's opened up his checkbook to
help fund some of these alternative kind
of like catalyst treatments and David
took me to a piece of property in
Michigan that he owns to go bow hunting
and I grew up gun hunting in Illinois
you know just for luck bird hunting you
know normal you know normal Midwestern
hunting and I had never picked a bow up
and I'm afraid that I'm like drinking
the kool-aid because it's like it's like
climbing like it is you it will consume
your life it's like a perpetual pursuit
of perfection that you'll never attain
and like it was super therapeutic for me
it was cool to pick up a bow and like
you don't have to go out and hunt you
could pick up a recurve or a compound
bow and go to the local archery range
and like the breathing I mean I don't
even want to pick up guns anymore like I
like I don't shoot I but going into the
backyard and shooting arrows into a
speed bag it was super therapeutic I
mean I'll second that usually
therapeutic I do think the breathing is
a big piece of it yeah it's you really
have to pay attention to sort of the
rhythm of the process yeah and there's
also something you know not not to
stretch too far but there's something
innate you know over let's call it
hundreds of thousands of years it might
be more sort of evolution
that has made holding and practicing
with a bow gratifying on a level that
sort of exceeds like the it's it's more
than the sum of its parts if that makes
sense it's kind of like it's like a tie
back to like the warrior roots right now
I mean I would you know I'm in total
novice like you know the target needs to
be like 20 yards for me for me to be
like confident hitting anything yeah I'm
no Tim Ferriss well no this is yet
another example of where I've stalled it
blue belt but I so I would say that and
this is something else that I wanted to
you know say before we left today is I
you know I had the honor of serving with
some of the most brave human beings that
were not Navy SEALs
during my time overseas in combat like
in Iraq in 2006 I served with both 32
and 35 Marine Corps infantry units and I
mean was able to like stand in combat
with some of the most heroic human
beings ever and there's a lot of those
guys and gals out there I just I don't
want you know the the SEAL Teams and and
soft in general is in the spotlight a
lot for better or for worse and there
are so many people out there that have
served this country with you know more
courage and honor than you know you know
I could ever admit to to serving you
know during my own time that I want to
make sure that they people understand
that that there's a lot of remarkable
human beings out there and you know my
hope is that you know being honest today
allows you know some of those folks out
there that are total badasses to be able
to come forward and and you know talk to
their their buddies and and you know
keep themselves healthy yeah than their
families and their families and you know
what we're lucky with in the SEAL
community we have
lot of benevolent support through great
organizations and I just I just don't I
think it would be a tragedy for these
other you know veterans to not receive
that same type of support so yeah it's
just it's you know I consider myself
like a conventional seal like I served a
lot and day like combat and alongside
conventional efforts during general
Petraeus's counterinsurgency doctrine
and you know I just that's where you
know kind of my my heart and soul as a
seal was was serving on the battlefield
during the day with with very brave men
well I'm so glad that we were able to do
this in person for a million reasons and
let me mention a few few organizations
that people can take a look at if they
would like and I've had some exposure to
a number of these so the Navy SEAL
foundation which is a four-star
nonprofit on Charity Navigator which we
could discuss in a separate time but can
you can check out the Navy SEAL
foundation a Navy SEAL foundation org
there's also the c-4 foundation which
supports active-duty seal families it's
C for letter C number four foundation
org and I will link to all these in the
show notes so people don't have to
scribble down notes so I'll come to the
URL for that in a minute but Special
Operations Warrior Foundation is another
and the station foundation I want to
mention a few other things and these
will all be in the show notes at Tim dot
blog forward slash podcast where you can
just search Nick Norris and all this
will pop up
of course links to everything people who
are interested in a few other adjunct
options potentially for say treatment
resistant depression I would encourage
to take a look at it's not a panacea
there is some addictive potential so you
should read the indications speak with a
doctor but ketamine can be one very
powerful tool particularly if you are at
a point where you're suffering from
the very bottom
meaning suicidal ideation is is one tool
that has has proven from a research
perspective and is is legal and
available and in clinics around the
United States and was only actually
recently approved for nasal
administration as well I think is is
very worth investigating for people
really in a dark place or know someone
who is there's a documentary called trip
of compassion which I just put out I do
not make any money from it I did it pro
bono to help get this film out which
covers specifically addressing PTSD and
using tools including psychotherapy and
MDMA there are some veterans in that
documentary and that's also a therapy
that is currently going through phase 3
trials so people are interested in
learning more about that can go to maps
or --g and look for the phase 3 trials
related to mdma-assisted psychotherapy
nick people can find you on instagram at
nick underscore norris 1981 and your
company which i would have already
mentioned at this point in the
introduction as well can you just give
us two just a short description of your
company yes so we have a sunscreen
company called um evaru and we invented
a zinc oxide only product that we have
some provisional patents pending on so
basically it's a healthy sunscreen you
know healthy for you and the environment
and you know the differentiator for us
is that we've solved all the poor
aesthetic issues that zinc has typically
it makes your skin white it feels
terrible it's thick and greasy we have a
product that goes on dry and clear and
is super gnarly water resistant so if
you're an athlete I mean we're endorsed
and partnered with the North Shore
Lifeguard Association out of Hawaii so
like kind of the the the special
operations of the lifeguard world I mean
those I have a profound level of respect
for those
guys I mean they they put themselves in
situations that I can't even imagine and
they they've used our stuff and then
it's the only sunscreen that there's
guys use so and I have a bunch at home
as we speak and people can learn more
about that at of our a.m. a VAR a.com do
you've any closing comments requests
anything at all that you'd like to say
before we wrap up I mean I just I
appreciate you giving me the platform to
share this you know if anything I mean
we talked a little bit about it
yesterday you know hopefully it's a
message of hope you know
and hopefully relabeling PTSD and mental
illness whatever other label people have
placed on on these issues
you know relabeling them in a positive
light and looking them at them as a you
know it's a currency that that people
have paid for some great personal growth
in other areas of their life yeah yeah I
think I I feel very confident that
certainly if we discard my my
long-winded soapbox moments I think you
did I think that you delivered upon that
really well today and I do think it's
it's a message of hope that's why I
wanted to have this conversation and
record it and share it and the fact of
the matter is you know if if so many
people not just you like you're one
example of someone who's been a at the
top of of many different disciplines and
I know scores more some of whom are
still too embarrassed or unwilling at
this point which is totally fair to talk
about it publicly but if if people who
are at those levels are experiencing
these things and contending with them
just as hundreds of thousands or
millions of people are who are listening
to this there doesn't have to be on top
of the challenge which is manageable and
addressable of developing the habits and
putting together the group activities
and maybe you
form and so on you don't have to add
shame to that right to solve list that's
it's it's not just unhelpful it's
unnecessary
anybody shames you or looks at you in a
negative light
because you've come forward yeah the you
probably don't have any room in your
life for them yeah yeah agreed agreed
this is this is really especially after
speaking and writing publicly about this
the the number of people who've come
forth to me publicly and in private the
types of people the the broad spectrum
from sort of private safe being a single
mom all the way up to fortune 500 CEO
leads me to believe that the these are
challenges which are the the norm and
that there need not be any shame in it
and there are tools that can help and I
think that you know hopefully they're
there there are others out there who are
also having these conversations but at
the very least you being willing to come
on and talk about this means a lot to me
certainly I mean I could have used
hearing you met at many points when I
was struggling in college and at other
times and so hopefully it'll catch catch
some folks and show them that you know
not only there's there light at the end
of the tunnel but there are very
practical steps you can take to 'ls you
can use that can aid you along the way
I'm here for you buddy if you need me
thanks brother likewise and to everybody
listening I mentioned again the show
notes we'll have links to everything
that we discussed at Tim DUP log forward
slash podcast you can just search Nick
Norris and the episode with all links
will pop up and until next time thank
you for listening
be safe stress inoculation to sleep and
see you next time
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email for me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by helix
sleep last year I focused on
dramatically improving a few things
surprise surprise
most notably the quality of my sleep
which seems to affect just about
everything this led me to revisit you
name it
my daily routine morning routine
exercise diet all the way to what I
slept on and I ended up getting all new
beds here in Austin Texas including
mattresses from helix sleep helix has
built a sleep quiz that takes two
minutes to complete and they use the
answers to match your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper
hot sleeper cold sleeper or you like
plush you like firm with helix there's
no more guessing or confusion just go to
helix sleep calm for slash Tim take
their two minutes sleep quiz and they'll
match you to a mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life that is
their promise for couples helix
candyman's to put the mattress down the
middle providing individual support
needs and feel preferences for each side
they have a 10 year warranty and you can
test drive your mattress for 100 nights
risk free right now helix is offering up
to 125 dollars off of all mattress
orders check it out get up to 125 off at
seelix slate.com fallen / Tim that's
helix leap dot-com forward / Tim for 125
dollars off your mattress order take a
look
helix sleep calm before / temple
this episode is brought to you by
LegalZoom which more than 2 million
Americans have used to help start their
businesses past guests even such as
while WordPress lead developer CEO of
automatic Matt Mullenweg now valued at
more than a billion dollars have used
LegalZoom to help with their business
needs specifically in his case to form
his company but LegalZoom isn't just for
launching your business with their
services include everything from helping
you to manage changing tax laws
reviewing contracts creating NBA's
non-disclosure agreements reporting
stuff
handling lease agreements and assisting
with really any other legal challenge
hurdle inconvenience that typically
takes time and effort away from running
your business the best part is that you
won't get charged by the hour because
Leo zoom isn't a law firm so they won't
be running the clock up and spinning
circles just to raise your bill instead
they just ask you to pay one low upfront
price for whatever it is that you're
looking to get Alucard style
so visit legalzoom.com and check out
their business section for all their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and the copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is folks but it's
titillating if you want special savings
enter promo code Tim T IM at checkout
capital T lowercase I M again take a
peek legalzoom.com and enter promo code
to him
[Music]
you
[Applause]
you
you
you